as you know your highness there's a lot
of concern here in this country and in
this region that a trump administration
will be less supportive of the Middle
East because of concerns over terrorism
for example immigration and the cost of
military support do you expect a
meaningful shift in US policy here well
you know it's no secret that the
relationship between being Saudi Arabia
and the Arab world in general and the
United States has not been very very
nice if I if I can just turn in the in
the last eight eight years or so they've
been very turbulent I think with the
Trump administration at least women let
get the [ __ ] strategy works plan focused
policy whereby at the end of the day mr.
Trump and you will represent the United
States in the whole world and I think
once he begins thinking deeply about the
the role of the Arab world and Saudi
Arabia and its support United States I
think religion will be a lot more
improved between between both between
both groups Saudi Arabian attaboy
Demonica inside the night seats so
regardless of what exactly it is he
tries to do you see it getting better
you know look I always like to
dissociate between candidates Trump
president electrum and present from we
already see have seen the growth and
advancement between the change between
between candidates Trump and prendick
Trump and I can assure that that the
change between president elect Trump and
per example bit also different your
royal highness Saudi Arabia is trying to
very slowly I should add wean itself off
of oil the deputy Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman has initiated a plan to
transform and transition this economy by
cutting government spending attracting
foreign investment and raising revenue
it is an enormous and unprecedented
undertaking is it going to work well we
have seen the brexit in UK we have seen
the surprise winner of mr. Trump the
United States the Lord's seeking change
and thanks God that Saudi Arabia what
Hamad bin Salman under his father King
Salman and with the support of principle
the knife
the conference - really - establish all
these new rules for Saudi Arabia to
lessen its dependence on dangerous
dependence on oil which have been really
asking for since more than five years
ago but thanks a lot is happening at now
so let's dependence on oil budgetary
constraints increasing revenues from
various areas so all these are very much
welcomed and supported by me personally
how do you demonstrate your support what
can you do to help him oh I mean I'm
continuously contact with the Prince
Mohammed and I meet the King Salman
every week once so so my support is very
much established but clearly right now
we are going to really invest in many of
the projects that he's talking about for
example I've just talked today for
example do the the just two hours ago
the the executive chairman of of Six
Flags and you know six flags being very
public about its coming in as
expectation to come Saudi Arabia and the
amusement park I just took them and we
just told them that we are international
investor than he knows obvious Kingdom
holding in order to invest of Disney in
Paris so he welcomed that and we ready
establish link with them right now to
begin having the private sector headed
by Kingdom holding to invest with him
well with six like this so we are
support them by having the private
sector and have and employ our money of
Kingdom holding and private sector to be
in support of public public sector money
which is a Saudi Arabia
your Royal Highness help people to
understand how delicate this balancing
act is between the royal family on the
one side of course and public servants
and the Saudi people on the other well
you know some members are royal family
like King Salman Hamad bin Nayef miss
vaneman a pleasant man our member
lauranmatt also argument officials now
in my case a member of family with I'm
private citizen I'm problem in private
sector so really it's a you know when
Prince the Prince of Hampton Salman
interacts with the business community
interacts with the government officials
here interactions capacity as being
about official